could i ask you first your royal harness
what was your instant impression well i
remember thinking what a very jolly and
amusing and and attractive 16 year old
she was i don't know what you thought of
me
pretty amazing
[Music]
sweet kind the princess has been the
best thing to happen to the monarchy in
centuries did you get a chance to see
her yes
diana is very big news everywhere she's
got the common touch
the prince realizes that he's taking
second place
by the way
a hollow and tormented marriage are
giving the british media and its public
little else to talk about just give me
wrong
so she's been pushed from the word girl
it's the media that's causing the
problems
lady
she's been through the worst that can be
thrown at him
i think we've got an unhealthy obsession
[Music]
i think she's very close to being a
monster
she has a sick mind she likes to be with
people she likes to be bloody well
that's ridiculous she has been
humiliated
when you put a modern person an ancient
institution they will be destroyed
the monarchy is in danger of too much
publicity at what point british people
say i don't want to hear anymore
what's wrong with us as a country
should this mean so much to us
[Music]
the people in there look at them
trapped
you